jimmy chang has been home on
unpaid leave since taiwan's government
tightened its pandemic restrictions
last week the gym he manages will be
shut
until mid-june at the earliest
it worries me a lot if the situation
gets worse
my income will be affected i may not be
able to support my family
until this month the island had been
reporting single-digit cases
it reported around 670 infections on
thursday
malaysia is also battling a surge
there's been a five-fold increase here
since
the start of the year this week it
recorded an average of 60 deaths a day
since monday its health services are
under strain
and the director general has warned the
country must prepare for the worst
the government has tightened
restrictions by among other things
banning domestic travel and social
activities
but it has resisted a full lockdown
citing fears of an economic disaster
the government has instead urged
malaysians to go on a self-imposed
lockdown
and stay home as much as possible in
australia's southern state of victoria
people will have to remain home except
for essential business
a new cluster of infections was detected
in melbourne this week
and cases are expected to rise in the
coming days
many countries in the region appeared to
have the virus under control
last year but they've fallen behind on
vaccination
you know vaccination is the only way to
lead us out of this pandemic
unfortunately the supply of the sins
in the whole asia is disproportionately
low because it will take one or two
years
for the whole region to reach the hermit
immunity the pace of inoculation is
slowly picking up
japan set to host the summer olympics in
july
during a worsening covet 19 crisis is
ramping up its vaccination campaign
vietnam once a success story but now
battling its largest outbreak of the
virus has set up a special fund
to drive its vaccination program
florence louis al jazeera kuala lumpur